"this message are delivered to you
the people of American"
The situation in Iraq and Syria is a
disaster. But there's one happy fact about this scenario
ISIS is stalled and in Iraq it's
actually losing ground.
If these trends continue ISIS will be unable to hold on to territory in Iraq in the foreseeable future.
When ISIS
swept northern Iraq in June 2014
they looked unstoppable. "How these
victories possible these victories come only
from Allah
and that is how with the small numbers of soldiers that we have we take these massive victories"
But their weaknesses began to be exposed starting
as early as August 2014
when ISIS made boneheaded mistake.
It invaded Iraqi Kurdistan and threatened Erbil
the Iraqi Kurdish capital.
"we will not stop fighting will not put down our weapons until you reach your lands."
The Peshmerga defended themselves and then turned
the tables on ISIS and began offensive
maneuvers
which seriously crimp ISIS' style in
northern Iraq.
bring every nation that you want to come
and fight us it means nothing to us.
moreover, there were Americans in Erbil and the
United States was not going to allow ISIS
to pose a serious threat to its own
citizens.
So, in August United States began bombing
ISIS to protect kurdish holdings
and to protect the Yazidi minority in Iraq
who ISIS threatened to exterminate.
"And to the leading to Obama , to Tony Abbott, I say this:
these weapons that we have the soldiers
who will not stop fighting will not put
down their weapons."
Iraqi army that was swept over June was
week disorganized and were people who
fled from the first site of battle.
It's smaller now
but it shown battlefield capabilities
particularly the special forces
in combat with ISIS and it's buttressed
by an enormous amount Shia militias.
These militias together with the Iraqi
army are much more disciplined and much more
effective than the scattered week Iraqi
army in June 2014 was
and now that ISIS is facing a serious
foe that has adapted itself to their tactics,
they're no longer is capable of taking anyone by surprise.
the US air strikes since August and September have been more effective than most observers suggested.
The reason that's true is ISIS'
obsession with territory. They wants to
openly defend territory and that means
putting troops
out in ways that make them vulnerable to
air power in conventional battles.
that's why US air strikes have been so
effective in disrupting ISIS.
"Bring your planes, bring everything you want to us
because they will not harm us. Why?
because we have Allah! And this is something that you do not have."
To say ISIS is losing
isn't to say that ISIS is going to
disintegrate sometime in the next year or so.
this may take a while. And moreover the
group may somehow reconstitute itself
as an insurgent group or terrorist group
after loses control territory.
The fact that ISIS is losing refers to the
fact that it it
increasingly incapable of holding on the territory which is its key mission right at the Islamic State
Shouting in Arabic